après deux ans de travaux sans
interruption la plaza st-hubert sera
entièrement ouverte aux montréalais
samedi pour des dizaines de commerçants
c'est la fin des maux de tête quotidien
il pousse enfin un soupir de soulagement
ça a été ardu ça a été de longue haleine
mais on est vraiment contents du
résultat qu'ils ont mais sans barrière
de nous ça a été des très longs travaux
mais le résultat est vraiment conclure à
l'artère commerciale est complètement
transformé les trottoirs sont plus
larges
des centaines d'arbres ont été plantés
deux espaces publics sont maintenant
accessibles et la marquise de la plaza
saint-hubert qui est sa marque de
commerce a elle aussi été modernisées on
en a profité pour bonifier la vie de 53
millions plutôt que d'avoir un gros
chantier que nous vu pareil comme avant
on a eu un gros chantier pleine rue
complètement transformé ou les jeux que
les gens peuvent se réapproprier les
redécouvrir les travaux de réfection
omis certaines propriétaire au bord du
gouffre mais selon la société de
développement commercial de la plaza
saint-hubert le bilan est somme toute
positif vieux que trois commerces qui
sont partis à cause des travaux fait que
pour nous c'est un jeu et un excellent
bilan
la fin des travaux et le nouvel
aménagement font aussi le bonheur des
gens qui fréquentent la plaza st-hubert
urgent parce que ça s'est amélioré
beaucoup c'est beaucoup mieux que
c'était je trouve ça plus convivial -
mais je recommence à la re découvrir
encore insatisfait il ya beaucoup de
monde dans le quartier je sais pas ça va
être bon plus le magasin je me serais
des années jusqu'à la russie demeure
très content les deux dernières années
ont certainement été difficile pour les
commerçants qui ont dû composer avec des
travaux de réfection majeure mais aussi
une pandémie mondiale
ils voient d'un bon oeil ce
réaménagement qui pour eux une occasion
de renouveau ici et me lemieux radio
canada montréal